sorry failing brainy spears had some
choice words for her family
in her latest instagram post on saturday
the singer took to instagram to continue
speaking out against her conservatorship
which is overseen by her father jamie
spears but in this latest message
britney also slammed her sister jamie
lynn come on
specifically this performance at the
2017 radio disney music awards
brittany was presented with the
ceremonies icon award and jamie lynn
surprised her sister on stage by seeing
a remix of till the world end
come on get me get me on the floor
dj what you what you waiting for
i was singing to her the whole time this
was this was for brittany
e.t caught up with the fellow performer
sophia carson following the tribute
and jamie lynn surprised for enjoying
the performance i know brittany was
completely surprised completely blown
away
brainy wrote in the message i don't like
that my sister showed up at an awards
show
and performed my songs to remixes
[Music]
brittany also clapped back at criticism
of the dance video she's been sharing to
instagram
she said she won't be performing on
stage anytime soon
because of the control her father would
have over the performances
am i going to take the stage again will
i ever take the stage again
i have no idea brittany wrote i'd much
rather share videos
yes from my living room instead of on
stage in vegas
she added my so-called support system
hurt me deeply
brittany received some supportive
messages in the comments she's just
so sweet and down to earth and really an
amazing woman
and i'm just so proud of her paris
hilton wrote yes live your life
beautiful
you deserve happiness and nicole snooki
pulitzi
left an invitation speak your truth
queen you can come perform in my living
room
any day brittany's message follows a
major win in her ongoing conservatorship
case
at a court hearing on wednesday brittany
was granted approval
to hire her own legal counsel i think it
would probably
be a good idea if the judge did
authorize an investigation
during that same court appearance
brittany was in tears as she spoke to
the judge
among her many emotional comments
britney said outright i want to press
charges against my father
for conservatorship abuse the question
here
is there a legal claim is there a
criminal claim i think a lawyer would
look at the totality of the case
and determine what's our best claim here
following the court hearing the
backstreet boys offered their own
message of support while speaking with
e.t
i was just covering the britney spears
conservatorship
hearing yesterday and you know i know
you guys have such a history there we
just wondered
do you have a message for brittany if
you could say something to her or
just a sentiment for how you're feeling
about what's going on with her right now
i
i i would say stay strong um hold your
ground
we will pray for you and i hope she gets
what she deserves which is her freedom
you